To get an idea of how hard it is to land Starship,
it’s difficult enough landing SpaceX’s
much smaller rocket, the Falcon 9.
As one of SpaceX’s commentators put it,
landing the Falcon 9’s booster is similar
to launching a pencil over the Empire State
Building, putting it in reverse, and having
it come back down and land successfully.
Or put another way, preparing the rocket
for re-entry to land vertically is like trying
to balance a broomstick on your hand in the
middle of a windstorm
which is clearly very hard to do.
Now take the difficulties of the Falcon 9
but multiply them and you get Starship.
The largest rocket ever.
As Starship prepares to send people to Mars
and back, SpaceX has to figure out how to
land this beast safely.
Starship enters Earth’s atmosphere in a
rather odd way.
It falls from the sky belly first after shutting
off the engines.
The belly flop helps decrease the velocity
of Starship.
The larger surface area increases air resistance
to slow its fall.
Kind of like how a skydiver maintains a horizontal
body position with their arms and legs spread
to control their freefall.
The arms and legs of the Starship are its
four flaps.
It then does a short flip to revert back to
a vertical position and reignites its Raptor
engines to get ready for landing.
In the case of prototype number 8, the vehicle
came in way too fast and blew apart when it
hit the ground.
SpaceX had more luck with later versions.
So, why doesn’t this thing just land vertically
like the booster of the Falcon 9?
Landing the Falcon 9 booster is easier because
it doesn’t go into orbit.
It lifts the upper stage into orbit, before
returning to Earth within minutes from a relatively
lower altitude.
So it never achieves super-high speeds.
Whereas Starship goes into orbit and travels
much faster than the Falcon 9’s booster.
SpaceX’s biggest hopes and dreams rest on
this spacecraft sending 100 people or 100
tonnes to Mars.
This is how the trip would be made:
Starship is lifted into orbit by the Super
Heavy booster, which then comes back to Earth.
It meets up with another Starship configured
as a tanker in order to refuel in Earth’s
orbit before making the long journey to the
red planet.
It could also fly to the moon in a similar
manner.
The booster isn’t required for the return
since there’s no deep gravity well to escape
from on Mars.
Starship flies solo, fueled by locally produced
methane.
Every step is a feat in itself.
But one of the most difficult is landing heavy
payloads on the surface of Mars.
It’s really, really, really hard to do.
Only about half of all missions to Mars have
worked out. The ones that failed either missed
the planet altogether, crash-landed, or their
signal was cut.
It’s much harder to land on Mars than on
Earth where our atmosphere allows the spacecraft
to glide gently down to the surface.
There won’t be anything like that on the
red planet - the atmosphere is too thin.
100 times thinner than Earth’s.
So it won’t be able to slow the vehicle
down.
Starship will plummet toward the surface of
Mars at 7.5 km per second or 4 and a half
miles a second.
The heat shield will protect Starship from
melting during atmospheric entry.
It’s made up of impressive hexagonal tiles
and is designed for multiple entries.
Tests have shown these hex tiles can withstand
temperatures of 2500 degrees Fahrenheit or
about 1400 degrees Celsius.
Because Starship is coming in so hot there
will be wear and tear just like the brake
pads of a car.
And, by the way, while this is happening,
there’s a communication blackout.
Those on Earth won’t be able to talk to
Starship because of the long time delay due
to distance - anywhere from 5 to 20 minutes
- so scientists can’t send commands in real-time.
Instead, Starship will be pre-programmed with
a set of actions.
It’ll be a flying robot that must rely on
its computers to land.
Here at Newsthink, we’ve imagined what Starship’s
landing legs might look like as SpaceX engineers
continue to refine their design.
We know they will be retractable - tucked
into the rocket to minimize air resistance
- and then spread out to maximize stability
for landing.
Musk has said the legs will be automatically
leveled to handle the uneven, rocky terrain.
They will also have to be tough enough to
withstand pummelling by massive dust storms
and radiation.
We’ve removed the dust from this particular
shot so you can get a better look at the legs.
They may not be needed to land back on Earth,
however.
SpaceX has the idea of catching Starship using
the launch tower with a grabbing arm called
Mechazilla - likely in reference to the villain
Mechagodzilla that confronts Godzilla in the
film franchise.
Dutch animator Tijn imagined what catching
Starship might look like, before stacking
it together with the Super Heavy booster to
get it ready for another flight.
This still untested strategy would significantly
reduce the turnaround time for launches.
And time is of the essence - especially if
you’re Elon Musk and your dream is to build
a city on Mars with a fleet of 1,000 ships.
Before ever taking off on this perilous journey
with people aboard, Starship will fly uncrewed
many, many times - perfecting launching and
landing.
The real success will be determined if and
when launches and landings become as common
as a plane ride.
Behind this vision of the future are incredible
engineers who are solving the problems needed
to make the Mars dream a reality.
If you’d like to improve your skills in
math, physics, and computer science, or simply
become a better problem solver, my sponsor
Brilliant can help and you can try it out
for FREE.
Brilliant is a website and app with incredibly
interactive courses that it doesn’t even
feel like learning in the traditional way.
If you want a quick overview of Calculus to
review some of the principles you may have
forgotten, Calculus in a Nutshell is perfect
for you.
There's something for everyone.
From exercising your critical thinking through
the logic course - one of my favorites - to
learning about cryptocurrency.
There are no tests and if you get stuck, you
can read the explanations for more.
You can sign up for Brilliant with my link:
www.brilliant.org/newsthink which is in the description.
And with my link, you’ll get 20% off Brilliant
Premium which gives you unlimited access to
all of the courses and is perfect for students,
professionals, and lifelong learners.
Thanks so much for watching.
If you like what you saw, don’t forget to
give it a like and subscribe.
For Newsthink, I’m Cindy Pom.